si efectivamente hoy había una gran
agenda pero sin duda el protagonismo ha
sido la guerra en ucrania como tú decías
voló demirel selenski se dirigió por
videoconferencia a los líderes y pidió
armas pidió ayuda y es lo que respondió
el g7 le vamos a ayudar hasta que sea
necesario y también anunciaron nuevas
sanciones contra moscú aunque todavía no
está lista la el nombre de las personas
que van a ser sancionadas y los tipos de
sanciones que se van a interponer sobre
todo se trata de tecnología accidental
que sirve por ahora a la industria de
rusia concretamente armamentística para
justamente dejar solo a moscú en esta
guerra y sin dinero pero también se está
discutiendo la idea de poner un techo al
precio del petróleo todavía no está
claro el método si poner un techo a los
productores oa los compradores oa la
cadena de servicios que sirve para
exportar el petróleo ruso bolo de
misiles que lo que dijo es que él quiere
que esta guerra termine a fin de año
porque tiene miedo del invierno de lo
que pueda afectar eso a las tropas
ucrania y en general dijo que quiere
contarnos cierto con el apoyo de
occidente que por ahora no se siente en
condiciones de sentarse a la mesa con
los rusos que no se sienten en una
posición de fuerza médica ahora cuál ha
sido la discusión alrededor del impacto
que ha generado la guerra en la crisis
de alimentos
si era otro de los temas de hoy muy
importante recordemos naciones unidas
dice que hay 300 millones de personas
alrededor del mundo que están en riesgo
de caer en hambruna hay 22 millones de
toneladas de trigo que están bloqueadas
en ucrania el granero del mundo porque
no pueden salir a raíz de esta guerra y
además habrá nuevas cosechas y no hay
donde poner esos granos ese trigo por lo
tanto era un tema muy importante hay una
ong con la que conversamos wang que
trabaja en ucrania pero también en
áfrica preocupada de que sobre todo el
g7 cualquier decisión que tome al
respecto la manteca escuchemos lo que
nos dijo una de sus portavoces
entonces en el g20 en roma' vimos como
los líderes dijeron ok vamos a hacer una
promesa que vamos a reciclar este dinero
gratuito que tenemos para que los países
en áfrica puedan
combatir cobit puedan combatir
los precios que aumentan puedan combatir
la crisis climática y puedan liberar un
poco el espacio fiscal para combatir
todas estas crisis y que paso a día de
hoy de esos
100 millones que se prometió en roma'
sólo tenemos 60 millones
los líderes del g-7 también se
comprometieron junto a las naciones
emergentes a la transición energética
pero no entregaron ninguna hoja de ruta
concreta